learn to say you to the world every
once in a while you have every right to
just stop
thinking
worrying looking over your shoulder
wondering doubting fearing hurting
hoping for some easy way out
grinding
grinding away at yourself stop it and
just
do
[Applause]
you belong in the most secret part of
you
don't worry about cool
make your own uncool make your own make
your own world if you fear make it work
for you
draw and paint your fear and anxiety and
stop worrying about big deep things such
as
to decide on a purpose and way of life a
consistent approach to even some
impossible end or even an
you must practice being stupid
dumb unthinking empty
then you will be able to do
the work you do is very good try to do
something bad try to do some bad work
the worst thing you could think of to
see what happens but mainly relax
and let everything go to hell
you are not responsible for the world
you're only responsible for your work so
just do it
don't think that your work has to
conform to any preconceived idea form or
flavor it can be anything you want it to
be but if life would be easier for you
if you stopped working then stop don't
punish yourself however i think that
this is so deeply ingrained in you that
it would be better for you to do
i have an agonizing reappraisal of my
work and change everything as much as
possible and hate everything i've done
and try to do something entirely
different and better and
maybe that kind of process is necessary
to me pushing me on and on and
well the feeling i could do better than
that i just did
maybe you need your agony to accomplish
what you do and maybe it goads you on to
do better but it's very painful i know
it would be better if you had the
confidence just to do this stuff and not
even think about it can't you leave the
world in art alone also quit fondling
your ego i know that you or anyone can
only work so much and the rest of the
time you are left with your thoughts but
when you work or before you work you
have to empty your mind and concentrate
on what you're doing after you do
something it is done and that's that
after a while you can see some better
than others but also you can see what
direction you're going sure you know all
that you also must know that you don't
have to justify your work not even to
yourself you also must believe in your
ability i think you do so try the most
outrageous things you can shock yourself
you have at your power the ability to do
anything
[Music]
you